je suis ingénieur dans un grand groupe
de btp il ya peu de secteurs industriels
marie à la fois la l'économie le social
et l'environnement dans mon secteur
on a tous et en plus on fait des choses
toutes différentes
on n'a jamais pu s'éloigner de notre
humanité
grâce à l' architecture on n'est jamais
vraiment rentré non plus dans la seconde
révolution industrielle
en 2008 j'ai décrit un véritable
bouleversement avec le grenelle de
l'environnement
tout est devenu subitement complexe
comme je suis ingénieur j'ai cherché à
comprendre vraiment comprendre ce que
j'ai compris c'est que dans une société
lorsque l'on change les règles du jeu on
doit changer la société et la conclusion
que j'en ai tiré pour le secteur du btp
c'est qu'il fallait qu'on abandonne nos
métiers etc on réorganise complètement
ces derniers
si on voulait apporter des réponses aux
enjeux du 21e siècle
l'enjeu du 21e siècle c'est
l'environnement
moi qui suis plutôt carré sans
sensibilité écologique particulière je
suis aujourd'hui un des plus ardents
défenseurs de la cause environnementale
parce que quand on prend en compte
l'environnement
on change tout les règles du jeu quand
on prend en compte l'environnement
on passe d'un modèle ou par principe les
ressources étaient infinies à un modèle
où les ressources deviennent fini tout
ce qui découle de ce principe de base de
ressources infinies et qui a structuré
notre société depuis la renaissance
s'effondre et il faut tout réinventer
les métiers qu'on a un prix font appel à
des compétences particulier
on ne peut pas être à la fois plombiers
électriciens maçons
on peut pas tout savoir mais alors
comment peut-on faire pour réinventer
les métiers en fait on a une chance
énorme dans notre époque c'est que le
digital est apparu ce que j'ai compris
c'est que le digital allait être
beaucoup plus puissants que l'imprimerie
pour transformer l'humanité parce que
grâce au digital
on ne transmet plus seulement du savoir
on peut transmettre du savoir faire et
donc du coup on peut s'affranchir de nos
limites nos limites humaines
d'apprentissage qui même si elles sont
énormes sont finis
grâce au digital on peut accompagner les
gens pour leur apprendre à travailler
différemment on peut leur permettre de
leur donner les compétences pour faire
face aux défis du 21e siècle qui sont
clairement de passer d'une société de
consommation à une société du recyclage
de passer d'une société de consommation
à une société de la connaissance sa
maquette quotidienne aujourd'hui dans
mon secteur
par contre au quotidien je vis un
véritable combat de boxe
j'essaie d'accompagner les gens dans
cette transformation
mais la résistance au changement est
énorme pourquoi parce qu'en fait nous
sommes encore rester dans la société du
xxème siècle consumériste ce qui me fait
le plus souffrir au quotidien c'est
lorsque les promoteurs de la société de
consommation qui sont principalement les
commerciaux le marketing la finance
reprennent les codes du xxème siècle
pour promouvoir le monde du 21e siècle
pourtant à l'opposé de leurs valeurs
cela me met dans une colère noire par
exemple vendre des panneaux solaires
quand dans certains cas cela se traduit
par une augmentation de la production
on dira construisait envoie pour pouvoir
stocker du co2 quand dans certains cas
le bois fait plus de huit kilomètres par
la route
tous ces mensonges ces abus sont
scandaleux et on peut mentir aux gens
justement parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
maîtrise des choses
la question que je pose aujourd'hui
c'est comment utiliser le digital pour
permettre aux citoyens de pouvoir
connaître le monde qui les entoure
lorsque l'on vend 20 panneaux solaires
on ne connaît ni son cycle de vie ni son
action sur notre écosystème
cela veut dire qu'on ne peut pas savoir
si le panneau nuit ou pas à
l'environnement
et si ce sont des gens du xxème siècle
qui vous vendent le panneau solaire il
faut faire attention parce que même si
vous disent que c'est bon pour
l'environnement personne ne peut le
savoir
moi qui suis ingénieur je suis toujours
incapable aujourd'hui de vous dire c'est
un panneau solaire est bon ou pas pour
l'environnement et je pense que le grand
public ne le sait pas davantage
par contre il ya une chose dont je suis
sûr c'est que le commercial lui ne le
sait pas
la solution à apporter est extrêmement
simple c'est de connaître les choses
je me suis beaucoup inspiré des makers
des circuits courts de certains
mouvements alternatifs dans ses
mouvements
on rencontre des gens qui sont souvent
en avance de phase i et dont il faut
s'inspirer pour trouver un chemin
durable pour l'avenir de notre société
un mec heures me disait un jour que sa
plus grande souffrance
c'était de ne pas avoir la connaissance
du monde qui l'entourent parce que le
fait qu'il n'ait pas la connaissance du
monde qui l'entourait ne lui permettait
pas d'agir sur le monde ne pouvait pas
détourner l' usage d'une machine à
coudre ou d'autres objets de la vie
quotidienne parce que il avait des
difficultés à accéder au plan là ce qui
est important à mon sens le plus
important aujourd'hui pour notre société
c'est la transparence sans transparence
nous ne pourrons pas apporter des
solutions durables
cette transparence elle se traduit
concrètement par un volume
d'informations gigantesque de toutes
formes qu'il faut structurer le digital
grâce à des modèles mathématiques
adaptée peut le permettre alors que tous
nos modes de communication actuels sont
incapables de nous permettre de
comprendre le monde qui nous entoure
progressivement par incompétence par
ignorance par dénis nous nous enfermons
dans un monde de mensonges
il faut arrêter ça quand on fait du
développement durable ont fait du
développement durable il suffit pas de
le dire il faut le faire j'en ai marre
de la couleur verte
des mots éco bio cela ne règle rien en
2012 je n'étais plus capable d'assumer
mon rôle de patron d'entreprise pourquoi
parce que je n'arrivais plus à vivre
avec ses contradictions
à tel point que je devenais agressif
avec certains maîtres d'ouvragés publics
face à leur cynisme
n'ayant plus rien à perdre j'ai proposé
à mon entreprise de changé le monde de
la construction
pour apporter des solutions durables
vraiment durable j'ai eu la chance qu'on
me fasse confiance
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer des
personnes qui m'ont guidé dans ce voyage
exploratoire
grâce à ces personnes j'ai pu apprendre
par la méthode à comprendre le lien
entre un simple clou sur un chantier le
réchauffement climatique
voire même le populisme j'ai continué à
tirer le fil
j'ai compris que si je reprochais aux
gens leurs difficultés à sortir du cadre
j'avais en fait moi même la même
difficulté parce que jusqu'à présent
j'étais resté enfermé dans mon propre
secteur est ce que j'ai découvert est
extraordinaire est tellement simple à la
faux c'est que dans toute l'économie
les humains répondent à leurs besoins
grâce à l'action d'autres humains il va
donc être possible de créer un langage
l'industriel universelle qu'on fasse des
avions des voitures des trains des
bateaux des bâtiments on a tous des
clients et on va tous échanger avec des
hommes et des machines
cela veut donc dire que le modèle
digital doit être au dessus de tous ces
secteurs
c'est là où j'ai dû faire mon lâcher
prise par rapport au bâtiment
aujourd'hui je ne me bats plus que pour
le bâtiment
je me bats pour tous les gens qui font
des choses avec leurs mains et avec
demand et machines et quand on mène
digitale au dessus de tout ça c'est
magique parce qu'on rapproche les hommes
on augmente leur savoir-faire est en
quelque sorte on donne
du sens mon vrai projet c'est de
permettre en europe de créer une
plateforme numérique industrielle
permettre d'accélérer le développement
de l'industrie du futur et pour
de nos startups et justement le btp dans
tout ça est resté un petit peu décalé
par rapport aux secteurs industriels
traditionnels
on a su conserver un réseau de 5 144
mille entreprises
rien qu'en france on a été des premiers
inventeur de l'open source
grâce aux matériaux qu'on utilise dans
le bâtiment 80% des français
ricol ce sont donc des makers en
puissance et surtout on fabrique
localement des bâtiments sont tous
différents
le btp est donc un formidable terrain de
jeu pour inventer l'industrie de demain
à condition de s'appuyer sur une logique
de modèle commun grâce à ce modèle on va
pouvoir collaborer contribuer à
accélérer accélérer l'innovation dans
notre secteur mais également dans tous
les secteurs industriels
je sais aujourd'hui que le btph et sera
l'accélérateur de l'industrie du futur
c'est donc un véritable enjeu sociétal
j'ai continué à tirer fils et j'ai été
confronté à deux problématiques
fondamentales qui sont un véritable pré
requis pour notre transformation
le premier c'est l'éducation parce que
chaque jour je suis effrayé de constater
qu'un tiers des gens qui sont
actuellement en activité seront en
décrochage numérique dans moins de dix
ans ils vont venir inemployables c'est
un véritable drame humain qui est en
train de se préparer en 1882 on rendait
l'école obligatoire pour tous jusqu'à 13
ans il est venu le temps pour notre
société
pour notre démocratie
de rendre l'école obligatoire pour tous
toute la vie pourquoi ne pas passer à la
semaine de 40 heures non pas pour
travailler plus mais pour apprendre plus
il faut également revoir le rôle de la
monnaie parce que si les citoyens
européens ne redevienne pas souverain
sur la monnaie ne pourront pas financer
cette transformation et nous irons à
notre perte
pourquoi parce que le capitalisme
financiarisé qui recherchent une
efficacité à court terme n'investira
jamais dans un modèle digital
contributif on ira alors vers un modèle
digital directif dans chaque secteur qui
va renforcer les inégalités et aliéner
les peuples
si nous ne parvenons pas à créer un
modèle digital partagé par tous et
contributif nous n'arriverons pas à
réorganiser nos instruits pour répondre
aux enjeux du 21e siècle
pire si d'autres continents arrive à
développer des plateformes numériques
industriel nous perdrons progressivement
notre souveraineté
dans tous les cas cela finira mal très
mal
probablement oui j'ai quatre enfants
je n'accepterai jamais que deux que l'un
d'entre eux puisse me dire un jour papa
tu n'as rien fait aujourd'hui je ne suis
qu'un petit colibri
j'essaie de me mettre en résonance avec
les autres colibri sur terre dans ce
monde violent est en mutation
ce qui me permet de vivre c'est l'amour
les coloris gris et la capacité que nous
avons tous à construire ce monde nouveau
chaque jour et si vous nous écoutez en
ce moment c'est que vous aussi vous êtes
probablement des colibris ou sur le
point de le devenir
les colibris ne font qu'un il est défis
du 21e siècle
on va aller relever ensemble
ce que je peux vous dire parce que cela
m'a profondément enrichi c'est qu'il
faut aller voir des gens différents
parce que derrière les grands concepts
de développement durable de révolution
numérique d'aplatissement des
organigrammes y aura bientôt une réalité
je l'expérimenté actuellement avec des
collaborateurs qui errent modéliser des
bâtiments sur ordinateur et aujourd'hui
m un bleu des chaussures de sécurité et
fabriquent ce qu'il dessine la réalité
est déjà en cours petit à petit les
frontières de nos chaînes de valeur
c'est face et ça c'est magique pour
faire se lâcher prise pour se réinventer
il faut se nourrir de tous les individus
de la chaîne de valeur de tous les
individus de la société
j'ai rencontré des philosophes des
makers des politiques des patrons du cac
des artisans des entrepreneurs des
ouvriers des gamers des gens de tout
horizon et c'est grâce à ces rencontres
qu'on peut aller chercher le point
commun qui nous unit quel est le point
commun qui nous unit c'est très simple
le point commun qui nous unit c'est
l'avenir de nos enfants et donc
l'environnement
on est plutôt tous d'accord le seul
problème c'est que nous n'avons pas la
même définition du mot demain pour un
philosophe
demain c'est dans 30 ans pour un
capitaliste
demain c'est dans une semaine et quand
nous discutons ensemble même si nous
sommes sur le même chemin
nous ne plaçons pas demain au même
endroit ce qui fait que lorsque nous
décrivons le paysage qui nous entoure
nous nous n'arrivons plus à nous
comprendre n'arrivons pas à nous
respecter
allez voir des gens différents de vous
sortez de vos corporatif
c'est du narcissisme si vous m'écoutez
en ce moment c'est déjà que vous faites
partie de ma communauté
allez voir des gens qui ne sont pas
comme nous sortez de votre zone de
confort pour les reconnaître c'est
extrêmement simple
la première fois que vous aller les
rencontrer vous ne pourrez pas les
confondre
et parfois même vous penserez ne pas les
aimer
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
ce que l'humain parce que le cadre
vesoul ouvriers veut on s'en moque
si nous laissons le digital se
développer sans abandonner nos
corporatisme nous allons automatisé
tracé contrôle et renforcer les
inégalités et aliéner les peuples si tu
as contre nous arrivons à sortir nos
corporatisme grâce à un monde digital
pour tous participatif
nous arriverons à créer l'industrie du
futur nos sociétés durables beaucoup
plus simple en apparence pour relever
les défis du 21e siècle
il est venu le temps pour l'humanité de
grandir
l'europe a tous les atouts pour le faire
c'est à vous de décider vous ne pourrez
plus dire à partir d'aujourd'hui à vos
enfants que vous ne saviez pas que vous
ne pouviez pas merci